غضب في عواصم العالم فهكذا ينتصر الشارع
العربي والغربي لغزه الذبيحه قدمت من
الشهداء الفا ويزيدون والقائمه مفتوحه لكن
الحراك الشعبي على اهميته لا يواكبه
النظام العربي الرسمي صمت وصفه نائب رئيس
الوزراء التركي بالخجل وقد يختفي وراء
الصمت تخاذل بل ربما تامر بحجه ان حركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس هي المشكله حماس
التي اقصاها مقترح تهدئه مصري مبكر لا عجب
انها رفضته وبينما تلتزم دول اقليميه كبرى
الصمت في العلن فانها تبدو لكثيرين اقرب
الى موقف مصر السيسي فهذا المعسكر انجازه
التسميه لا يرى في غزه سوى اتصال فكري
لحماس بجماعه الاخوان المسلمين التي لا
يربطه بها
كبيد فهل يبرر ذلك التقاعس عن نصره ابناء
غزه في وجه ثالثه الحروب الاسرائيليه
عليهم من تركيا وقطر جاءت حتى الان اكثر
المواقف وضوحا في ادانتها للعدوان
الاسرائيلي على القطاع ودعم المقاومه هناك
جهود الدوحه وانقره كان لها بصمتها في
الحراك الدبلوماسي الذي انتهى الى اجتماع
باريس الباحث عن اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
متاخرا تحرك المجتمع الدولي لكنه فعل فلا
مجال للتحركات الب
الخجوله والمتردد بعد ان هزت صور الضحايا
من اطفال غزه ونسائها الضمائر الحيه عبر
العالم لكن هذا الحراك املاه ايضا على بعض
حلفاء اسرائيل صمود المقاومه والانتصارات
المبهره التي تحققها على جندي الاحتلال
انتصارات نفضت التراب فجاه عما كان يعرف
بمعسكر المقاومه
والممانعه الهدف كل المقاومه فلسطين في
احدث خطاباته اعتبر العام لحزب الله ان
حماس انتصرت في غزه وانها ستصنع الانتصار
الاخير وجد حزب الله اذا في خضم حربه
الداعمه للنظام السوري بعض الوقت ليبارك
انتصارات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مقاومه اظهرت لطهران وحلفائها
قوه لا تستمدها منهم بالضروره انها غزه
الفاضحه غزه التي اسقطت كل
الاقنعه